so we have unfortunately fallen so far
uh in terms of the discourse that is
considered
i don't want to say typical or
acceptable maybe typical is a good word
not normal and acceptable but
unfortunately what has become typical in
the modern
sort of discourse of the american right
wing that over the last week we had
multiple calls to violence not only from
former president donald trump but his
former national security adviser michael
flynn
and it barely got any attention it
barely received any reporting i
mentioned it monday when we talked about
the whacked trump rally over the weekend
and it was one of 10 or so clips that i
played for you
but
it really has not gotten the attention
that it should get given that we know
that their followers are not only
capable of violence
but they're willing to do violence as
january 6th showed us among other
instances of political violence so as a
reminder
what are we talking about here's donald
trump over the weekend when he called on
his supporters to quote lay down their
very lives to fight
marxism and critical race theory
remember this anything getting critical
race theory out of our schools is not
just a matter of values it's also a
matter of national survival we have no
choice the fate of any nation ultimately
depends upon the willingness of its
citizens to lay down and they must do
this lay down their very lives to defend
their country if we allow the marxists
and communists and socialists to teach
our children to hate america there will
be no one left to defend our flag or to
protect our great country or its freedom
lay down our very lives to fight
marxism socialism communism and people
against people who want to teach
critical race theory
this is not only unhinged it's not only
based on things that aren't even really
taking place in this country but it's
targeted at a group of people that are
willing to get violent michael flynn
spoke to a q anon conference a few days
ago michael flynn one of donald trump's
former national security advisers and he
was talking about
charging the machine gun nest again more
violent imagery and language
can you two charge the machine gun nest
maybe i'm just asking to dig a little
bit deeper there
or hold this side of the line
or form up because we're going to
counter attack over here and that
counter attack is we're going to go
after school boards
and though and then those those people
those people that then fight them back
we got this problem in iowa right now
and these are republicans yeah
so listen um
you can argue that part of the rise of
trump was the media
gave him too much attention very early
in the republican primary that's a fair
criticism that can be made of corporate
media
we're now seeing the opposite problem
which is
now that he and they have tens of
millions of followers who would still
vote for them if he ran again today
he and his associates like michael flynn
are using violent imagery and alluding
to calls for violence and it's not
getting coverage anymore and of course
the right the ideal situation would have
been the opposite they should have
ignored and modestly ridiculed him in
the beginning
which might have prevented a lot of what
ultimately happened but now that this i
mean you know we it's sort of a
neo-fascist movement now that it is an
obvious and real danger to the united
states they should be doing their job
and shining a light on what it is that
they are doing and unfortunately you
know the people that are already in this
circle
they're going to suck it up uh and
absorb it no matter where it airs that's
the reality so it is a bit of a no-win
situation and at the end of the day the
people that did the inciting really need
to be held accountable and that includes
up to it including trump and it's not
looking particularly like that's going
to happen
i have some unbelievable video to show
you
of a missouri state senator asking a 14
year old transgender girl
about her genitals and as vile and
disgusting as this video is this is
state senator from missouri eileen i'm
sorry elaine
elaine gannon speaking to 14 year old
trans girl avery jackson whatever your
view is
about
trans bathrooms or sports or whatever
can we all agree that this line of
questioning is not only disgusting but
it also
completely exposes
the ignorance of the state senator about
trans issues let's take a look at this
you're in the ladies room and then you
realize somebody else is in there that's
doesn't have a female
has a male body instead of a female's
body i mean it just causes some issues
there
now did you do you guys understand that
this it's that it's almost genius it's
inadvertently genius the state senator
says you know it's really a problem
you've got a girl's room and then all of
a sudden someone goes in
and they've got a male body part right
and it causes a lot of problems and
confusion and the 14 year old
trans girl goes
no because nobody realizes what's going
on you're not checking out genitals and
the state senator goes well people
probably don't realize that you are
biologically male because you have long
hair now the the brilliance of this is
this is the entire point it nobody know
it doesn't matter nobody's affected by
things they're not aware of they're not
checking genitals in the bathroom and
she looks like a girl for lack of a
better uh uh term
so she's saying well people don't even
realize so so then what is the problem
if a tree falls in the woods and nobody
hears it did it really make a no it
doesn't make a noise or you know
whatever
if you've got a trans girl in the
bathroom
and it looks like uh uh um nobody is
paying particular
attention to the genitals
and nobody's eyebrows are raised then
what are we even really talking about
here
are you gonna go through the
procedure
what you want to do is not let people do
that
your whole argument here is the fact
that you don't want people to give back
a bathroom no one
gets known as
looking at what depending
themselves kids wanting to play sports
with their friends
so you guys get the point state senator
wanting to know
what are your genitals and do you plan
to get the ones that i
um the the fundamental so there's two
things that go on here one is a
fundamental misunderstanding of sort of
like what goes on in bathrooms that
that's number one and that's been we've
we've been aware of that for years but
number two it's also sort of the blowing
up of small pieces of this entire issue
of just treating people with dignity and
respect and kind of moving on to solving
the real problems we have in society
trans sports as i've said before
are there questions to just like figure
out about about uh tran transports yeah
it's it's fine there's leagues that deal
with that and
sure figure it out but it's not really
the main issue when it comes to the
issue of trans rights and transphobia
the bathroom thing again
when we look at is this really a problem
are these
predators that they say will just be
lurking everywhere if all of a sudden uh
people are able to use the bathroom that
matches their gender identity it just
doesn't happen it's not actually a
problem and uh just a very very vile
line of questioning here if you're just
listening we'll have all these clips up
on our instagram and you can let me know
your thoughts on this by finding me on
twitter at dpakman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
the david pakman show is of course a
viewer supported program that depends
counts on your membership support you
can sign up at joinpackman.com
it's the new hot thing it really is you
can use the coupon code wow 22
if you would like a discount off of a
membership at
joinpacman.com
let's hear from people in my audience
we do these via discord which you can
find at davidpakman.com slash discord
let's start today with yarrow from
brooklyn yarrow you're on the air i hope
i'm pronouncing that correctly
hello david it's ciara yaro okay i
apologize no worries thank you for
answering my call it's good to be on the
show my pleasure uh the question i
actually had was um i live in brooklyn
in the russian speaking part of it and
uh the conversation's been going along
uh going around about what's going to
happen kind of with ukraine and russia
and i was actually curious about your
personal opinion what do you think will
kind of happen kind of in all of this do
you think that
russia will kind of collapse from
sanctions or do you think it's going to
more or less turn into a win
so i'm kind of curious as to your take
on it i think by the way are you like
down in brighton beach
yes i am okay beach beautiful area
in the summer certainly yeah um so okay
i mean listen uh i think at this point
we're we're all really just guessing but
i think that regardless of what happens
militarily
um
russia's economy is going to be in very
bad shape for at least years to come as
a result of the sanctions absolutely i
don't i'm not leaning in the direction
of russia's going to take ukraine i i
don't think that that's the most likely
scenario i think sort of
there's it's not one or the other thing
so there's more than one possibility but
i think the most likely scenario is that
there's some off-ramp created for putin
where he saves a little bit of face but
not that much and russian troops stay in
some regions of ukraine like the donetsk
and luhansk and sort of like things are
just not good for anybody
moving forward for many years like that
i think is on balance the most likely
outcome
yeah that is the general fear among kind
of the russian and ukrainian population
here as well in brighton yeah yeah yeah
yeah uh i mean what the i now
are the russian folks you speak to
opposed to what putin is doing
for the most part yes yeah
that makes sense that makes sense and
everything's still good at coney island
and everything
uh yeah
i mean for the most part you could kind
of tell in brighton beach the atmosphere
has been a little bit depressed in the
last few weeks just people aren't just
cheery even by russian standards right
ukrainian standards but you know
hopefully it'll pass with time fair all
right very good i appreciate the call
thank you very much hope you have a good
day there great to hear from brooklyn
always great
let's go next to
oh i don't know i mean it's just so it's
so hard to know where to go
how about um logan from philly logan
you're on the air
uh
just barely uh it sounds like you're
under water and your volume is going up
and down
uh all right do you you want to try the
recalling like after another call i
could try switching oh you know what now
it just got a little better what's
what's on your mind
all right yeah um
so uh first off of ukraine uh i kind of
have two uh areas of questions um
the first is uh do you think zielinski
as a comic will have uh
um uh like what kind of influence he'll
uh
um
uh
uh
do you think zielinski as a comic will
have influence on what is uh politically
viable
in america or uh already changed what is
seen as politically viable in america
and uh do you think uh artists are
better suited for governance as a
society because their profession
requires them to
understand people and human nature in a
deeper way than politicians do
yeah
there's a lot there let's go through it
one by one because i don't i don't want
to get any of it let any so first of all
in terms of what's politically viable in
america
we had sort of an actor president
already in ronald reagan and then we had
a failed businessman in trump so like i
don't even think we need to look at
zelensky to impact what's viable in
america we we've already we've already
kind of seen that so that's one piece
the second piece i find more interesting
which is
actors performers
are professionals
in how their demeanor and delivery are
perceived by audiences and so that's a
very good skill for elected officials to
have so i'm not going around demanding
movie stars become politicians in any
way but i think it's it's definitely
clear
that some of the skills that performers
have do lend themselves really well to
being public figures for sure elected
officials
okay now you're really breaking up so
i'm going to let you go we were able to
hear the first two questions it's just
breaking up it's very very bad but it
was great to hear from you a very very
interesting question actually
let's go next to attack from denmark
attack you are on the air
yes hello uh thank you for taking me
again it's been a while it has you know
i'm watching a danish uh police i'm
watching the danish version of house of
cards this program called borgen it's
fantastic
ah bowen yeah yeah i'm quite well aware
of that one great show and a great show
absolutely anyway my question actually
was um
so i know from uh you're covering that
you spend a lot of time talking about
like the us reaction to the entire
crisis in ukraine right
now
my question actually is what do you
think actually um the role of the eu is
going to be in this overarching crisis
and actually if this ukraine crisis and
the war happening currently is in many
ways going to be a watershed moment in
transforming the european union into a
truly global actor
my thought on that is that what the eu
does is going to kind of be led by what
happens within nato i i actually think
that while these are obviously nato is
one thing and it's a shared defense
organization the eu is sort of a
political and economic alliance and it
it's not it overlaps with nato to some
degree but it is not nato
my belief and expectation is because
what is happening in ukraine
is
at its core
a military invasion by russia which is
having economic and political
consequences tell me if you think i'm
naive i think the eu
will to a great degree take a signal
from what nato ultimately does or
doesn't do depending on how much longer
this invasion continues
that's interesting so i would actually
to some degree disagree where i think
that until now the eu has taken a lot
more initiative than nato has so one of
the big things that happened on the 27th
of february you know around the time
period when germany announced their
massive hike in defense spending and so
forth is that the eu essentially
announced that they were going to
facilitate and coordinate the arms
exportation of weapons to ukraine and
you've probably heard about the entire
deal if you know the idea of polish
fighter jets being sent to ukraine as
well right of course that was a proposal
originally started by the european union
it was shai michel one of the leading
people in the eu who said they were
going to do it then they found out that
they didn't really have the capacity to
do it so that's how the u.s got involved
in trying to buy the jets from poland
and then send them over to ukraine but
the interesting thing of that is that
many of these arms exports and so forth
are in many ways facilitated through the
eu and not through nato and that's
something brand new for you know an
organization that historically there's
been a lot of contention around the idea
of um it having any type of military
role you know the eu army being
obviously a very contentious thing but i
don't disagree with you but here's why i
i don't disagree with you about what has
taken place here's the reason why i
think now nato may be more of a
benchmark than the eu which is
at this point we're getting to the
question of what military resources are
going to be deployed uh zielenski has
now asked canada and the us and others
for a no-fly zone he has asked for more
uh weapons and and more things which i
think now the next steps are really
military questions that's why this is
just my opinion we're just two people
with opinions this is why my thought is
in the next 10 to 14 days
nato
may be much more of a guidepost than the
eu but
either one of us might be right we might
both be wrong who knows
yeah absolutely and i do think on
another level i mean from the economic
perspective the eu sanctions against
russia have been quite substantial yeah
i mean
it's uh the us obviously has also done a
lot but considering the russia's economy
is way more connected to the european
union than the united states without a
doubt pretty it's pretty crazy to see
like the amount of stuff the eu managed
to bring out in a incredibly short
amount of time especially when you think
about the fact that the eu always has a
reputation of being you know a very slow
actor that always takes a while to
respond to anything absolutely yeah no
it's going to be i mean i don't want to
be
i it's going to be interesting to watch
you know people are dying so it's not oh
i'm interested and don't care that
people are dying there's a crisis but it
will also be interesting to see how this
is dealt with by by the eu in the coming
weeks
absolutely and obviously it's also a
very personal thing for me because i
have friends in ukraine um i mean i one
of my friends is currently fighting in
kharkiv
and has been engaged in combat so it's
you know it's a very very terrible
situation to sit here in you know my
comfort in denmark and like watch people
going through hell people i know
it's horrifying horrifying let's hope it
comes to a conclusion as soon as
possible with as little death as
possible
absolutely yeah thank you for taking my
call david
all right thank you very much there it
is etc from denmark
let's go
next to
where are we going next it's not clear
let's go to jt from south carolina jt
you're on the air
hello can you hear me yes i can
oh nice to meet you david likewise in a
long time i'm a long time watcher um
i just want to know have you recently
been seeing the things circulating on
social media regarding
trapped african exchange students in
ukraine and the treatment they've been
facing from the
uh the authorities there i have seen it
and uh there there were some incorrect
reports about what was going on and some
good reporting as well
i have not read anything about it in the
last three or four days is there
something in particular going on now
that i've maybe missed
well no it's just i'm i'm calling from
south carolina and i've been talking
with a lot of people in my community and
you know the black community and how
they've how do you basically perceive
this whole situation and i find that a
lot of people in my community and i'm
not by no means speaking for everyone in
my community just the people i've
personally spoken with i find that a lot
of them have a hard time garnering
sympathy for the ukrainians
because that's all you see on social
media nowadays with the ukrainians being
under constant threat from the russians
how the united states is sending
billions over there in aid and how the
media is shining its light on this
humanitarian crisis which i agree it's
terrible that's going on
yet we aren't shining the same light on
people suffering in south american
countries or in
in african countries that are facing
similar threats i mean right yeah you
know that's um that's always an issue
and here's the thing jt you know we i've
talked on my program endlessly about
why what determines what makes the news
and what doesn't and there's all these
different factors and one of those
factors is certainly
who is it that is being oppressed that's
a factor 100 percent that's a factor
what is the what what is the profile of
the people being oppressed other factors
include
is it an oppression
that has a clear beginning middle and
end and this is why sometimes
long-term suffering gets less attention
than an individual crisis that's like
okay russia is about to invade they've
invaded there's now an invasion and in
principle at some point that invasion
will stop that also is a reason why
certain things get more attention and
other things get less attention so i
think those are all legitimate things to
talk about it doesn't justify in any way
what russia is doing
and the value in repelling the invasion
so yeah i mean i i totally get what
you're saying thank you thank you and
and one final thing i wanted to point
out is
it's as if the republicans have had a
whole 180
about the immigration status of ukraine
they want to bring a lot of ukrainians
over here yet we just expelled over 4
000 haitians just last year
i know last year i know
if you want to find hypocrisy
and fickleness
look at american immigration policy that
is without a doubt that you can always
count on that
oh well thank you my friend for taking
my question i'm finally glad i finally
got on the show i appreciate it so much
jt it's been a pleasure thank you
thank you all right there's jt from
south carolina
making a number of different important
points let's go next to charlie from
toledo you're on the air charlie
hi sir how you doing i'm doing well sir
thank you
good i'm at work so it's pretty loud so
i'll get off pretty soon is there a
lathe you could maybe run to make it
even louder
yes sir i'm at a lathe right now okay
good all right what's going on good
guess
the uh the question i have is is really
an observation which is
i hear this talking point a lot about
school lunch
you know it shouldn't be free because
kids are going to become socialists
right
but
that
school from the students perspective all
of school is free so why don't we make
them pay tuition for public school
that's basically the observation yeah
and i mean it's it's absurd on a number
of levels which is also like
it's always kind of free to the students
because most of them are just getting
money from their parents anyway
and also it's all sort of not free
because it's all being paid for by their
parents property taxes or if their
parents rent by the property taxes that
their parents rent is paying for for
whoever is the landlord i mean it's all
kind of absurd even the use of the word
free is kind of silly because
most people once you get past third
grade you kind of understand nothing's
really free it's just who's paying for
it and you're right like there's no big
tragedy in kids not having to bring cash
for school lunch so we're we're going to
be okay as a society even with free at
the point of sale school lunches
sir i agree thank you for taking my call
all right thank you very very pithy and
concise uh okay we're gonna take a very
quick break we'll keep taking calls so
don't hang up if you're holding on to
talk to me we'll be right back
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show let's get back to the
phones where many of you are waiting to
speak to me we do these calls via
discord
davidpakman.com slash discord let's go
we are going to try again
our good friend eric from cancun eric
welcome let's hope your connection is
steady today
hi david gomez
and the thing i'm going to tell you last
week is that do you know the concept of
how comes racer yes i do occam's razor
of course
because first of all in philosophy a
racer is when you want to get rid of an
unnecessary theory when you want to
explain something and you don't want
complicated explanation so british will
and malcolm going to explain that the
simplest explanation is the correct one
if it gives a better or the same results
as the other complicated ones yeah eric
can i explain it in a slightly different
way
um
for example no no but eric what i'm
saying is would you allow me to give my
explanation of occam's razor is it okay
if i take 15 seconds and do that
okay okay
the way i think of occam's razor is
if we have two competing explanations
for some
phenomenon
and
both explain the phenomenon equally well
but one requires fewer assumptions and
is generally simpler
we would tend to favor the simpler
explanation that's how i think about
occam's razor eric if if that's okay
um yeah the simplest explanation for a
word to fly is that he flaps his wings
and becomes lighter than air the
simplest explanation for a boat to float
is that its shape can create a vacuum of
air that makes it float because he is
then less dense than water the simple
explanation for biden to be present is
that in 2020 everyone started to hate
trump because of being awful
and i think that that concept would
balance out the wackiness of the
internet and social media
and i heard that concept in my
philosophy class also from my dad and in
one episode of the simpsons when every
all the adults were drinking the erotic
tonic that homer and they were selling
and the kids were wondering why their
parents were keeping them out of the
house while they were doing the
hanky-panky lisa said that maybe because
they are reverse vampires they must go
home before dark wait a second eric is
that a simpsons episode or you're saying
your dad has an erotic tonic that he
drinks
that's from the second part is from matt
simpson's episode my dad also told me
about the concept of falcon's racer and
also in my philosophy class
that's beautiful eric you've really said
it all today
and it's because conspiracy theories
want to feel like james bond or any
other super spy from the movies but
instead of learning how to hack enemy
computers and martial arts and looking
good with a martini and a tuxedo they're
making full of themselves don't you
think i agree with you completely i
agree with you completely eric remind us
how old a guy are you
i'm i'm thirty thirty okay all right
eric great to hear from you i appreciate
it still good the weather in cancun is
still beautiful as always i assume
um it's a bit cloudy right now would you
prefer if i'm your weatherman or your
guillermo
i actually like hearing about the
weather in cancun it really lightens the
mood
if you want to come might have a good
airbnb place if you want okay yeah let
me follow up about that okay
okay i'll give you an email thank you
bye all right there is eric gonna hook
me up with an airbnb in cancun love it
let's go next to
ashton from california
just barely uh what kind of a device are
you on
a really cheap headset oh all right okay
what's on your mind i'll pump up your
volume here
thanks my question is uh i know there's
a lot um
we could view the ukrainian war uh
they're the russian invasion as a net
negative obviously but i was wondering
would you
do you think that you could at least
concede there might be some positive
aspects to this war and the the thing
that i keep thinking about is
i
we hear a lot um
in the news recently especially as it
relates to like um the conservative
party in canada how because of this war
there's a lot more scrutiny coming uh
come
coming on to political parties like the
conservative party about the kind of
dark money that's funneled into them and
the same thing could probably be said in
the united states with
funding in the republican party from
certain uh russian oligarchs and whatnot
and do you think that
maybe a silver lining in this war might
be that there's more scrutiny on that
now
maybe you know if you said to me
obviously we all concede that what's
happening is terrible and there's loss
of life and destruction of uh
all sorts of things that that we hold
dear if you say can you find any silver
linings one thing that i am kind of
thinking about is
we've seen the right in the united
states
as well as you know the right in hungary
and brazil and other places really cozy
up to these dictatorial authoritarians
like putin over the last five years and
one of the silver linings of what is
happening right now i hope will be that
there will be newfound skepticism and
kind of a return to
recognizing the disaster that these
dictatorial authoritarians are so that
like if you said to me what do i think
is potentially the best silver lining it
would be that
okay yeah i agree thank you very much
all right thank you very good call very
good question
um let's go to
kellen from ukraine are you in ukraine
kellen
hi david can you hear me yes i can
um
i live in kiev and i've lived there for
the last 11 years
um
but i actually came back to the us for
business on february 1st oh okay
but my wife
my cat and uh all of her family are
still in ukraine she actually just got
out of kiev
uh with an armed guard last week and
went to the west
wow and do you like so okay talk me
through the logistics of that do you
hire an armed guard to help your wife
get to the west of the country
so her dad is fairly well connected um
he's
a uh
director of a regional hospital in
western ukraine okay so he has a lot of
people who owe him favors i see and so
he was able to talk to one of his
connections uh who happened to be in
kiev at the time of the invasion
and he had special military permission
to be out after curfew and he was also
allowed to carry a concealed weapon so
he came to our apartment
and took our car
with my wife and cat and some of her
belongings so the cat went with your
wife that's good to hear at least
now let me ask you this
have you have you abandoned not you but
have you together as a unit
are you planning to go back to kyiv when
um
as soon as
the proper number of russians have been
set home in body bags wow
so in other words you're not abandoning
kiev you're just waiting for the
violence to end
yeah and i i left there on february 1st
for business purposes to come back to
the u.s yeah and was
was planning on returning but
um it's not it's not possible i mean
it's very hard to even get back into
keeve right now even if you want to
unless you have some kind of
military protection then i'm not a
trained soldier
um i and the ukrainian government has
asked weekend warriors to stay away yeah
and that's exactly what i would be so
i'm respecting that uh that call from
the government and are you american
married to a ukrainian woman or are you
ukrainian
i'm american married to ukrainian i have
residency in the country okay um
yeah we we have a couple of apartments
in kiev um
a rocket that was fired into the city uh
landed near our bank which is about two
blocks away from our uh our home oh wow
and
destroyed quite a bit of it and knocked
out all the windows in the surrounding
area so so can you talk a little bit
about you know in the news we see
russia has has bombed random apartment
buildings and then later you'll hear the
the attempt at a rationalization by
saying well we believe dissidents
and combatants were planning violent
activities in those apartment buildings
do you know anything about that is it
literally just like all of a sudden just
a missile hits an apartment building
uh so the territorial defense forces are
set up basically in every district in
the city
so there are
people who have weapons on the ground in
quite a few places in the city but
like i just saw um
the destruction around lukiana
lukianovka metro station which is about
10 minutes away from our apartment yeah
and
i didn't see any military on the ground
near that metro station
but it wouldn't surprise me if
there were
territorial defense forces in and around
that area because it is a major metro
station uh it's fairly deep so in a
literal sense when russia says well
those apartment buildings
in or right outside of them had uh
forces ukrainian forces
uh
every
room of every building in ukraine right
now has people that are willing to kill
russians in it right right right right
so it just sort of yeah wow
wow all right and then so and for the
time being you're just hanging tight in
the u.s
yeah i'm actually i'm in austin with my
younger brother um
and
you know still trying to go about
business life as as much as i can i've
been doing quite a few
interviews with uh with local media back
in my home state of nebraska
just trying to get the word out and this
was actually part of my
what uh what i wanted to ask you about
is
i have firsthand experience of living in
that country
for 11 years um
get getting to know thousands of
ukrainians um
and never seeing any kind of neo-nazi
movements or anything
other than the very far right which like
the azov battalion does have
uh very right-wing leanings and there
are some people but not any more so than
than there are in any other country in
the world i mean their jewish president
got i think was 71 or 73 of the vote
so
i've talked with a lot of people in the
u.s
who are just
repeating ad nauseam
the same russian propaganda that i got
to hear aplenty uh from
uh russian media and are the people
repeating that stuff in the u.s and your
experience do they tend to be more on
the right or the left in the u.s
right wingers every single one okay okay
well my question is if if i can't
convince them
um
having lived in the country for 11 years
participated in the maidan revolution
on the ground
and
i actually have first-hand knowledge of
this kind of stuff what hope is there
for any kind of uh
intelligent conversation
about when we should put boots on the
ground when we should go in there how
much protection we should provide them
why we should care about them if i can't
convince them of that
what hope is there of anyone else to
convince them no regardless of your
views as to what the answers to those
questions should be uh with the people
you're describing you're not going to be
able to have a real sensible
conversation about those issues sadly
but you're just not
all right yeah
well thanks for taking my call and for
listening all right well listen let's
hope everybody in the family and uh
everybody in ukraine stays safe okay
all right cheers all right there is
kellen who lives in ukraine
um let's speak to
uh let's speak to evan from boston evan
you were on the air
hi david can you hear me yes i can
hey i'm actually
a new new follower new listener so i
really appreciate the show
um and appreciate your views on things
thank you um
and my question is you've talked about
this a little bit if you have
uh
friends or family that
lean
lean republican
um
but
you know kind of bought into the trump
thing and are leaning away from it but
you know if he becomes the republican
nominee again
you know we'll probably
vote republican again um you know how do
you facilitate conversations maybe with
folks who aren't
hopefully in my opinion right like not
too far gone right
maybe they are
you know i don't know because i don't
have any people like that in my family
now
my my girlfriend does have some people
in her family who are
hard right
trumpists but they live in a different
part of the country and neither sheen or
i really have any contact with them i
mean we see what they're posting to
facebook but i don't i don't know what i
would say because i just don't have any
people like that in my family
that's a
how does um here's a good question how
does your
how does your girlfriend feel about it
as she's the one with the uh the
familial ties if you know what i mean
yeah i mean she thinks that they're
wrong about everything and does not
engage in any political discussions with
them whatsoever
gotcha but still kind of does she
facilitate a
um a healthy relationship healthcare
relationship yeah she has very little
relationship with most of those people
gotcha yeah
yeah that's how
i mean just that's how i'm
slowly slowly going and my wife is
i guess in a similar position as you
where she has no relationship with these
folks at all and here's the thing i
don't think any one thing is the right
thing to do is that when peop i get this
question a lot
how should i maintain or not maintain or
how should i confront people
it's all about what kind of a
relationship you want to have some
people legitimately say i
value family no matter what they think
and i want to maintain a relationship so
we will agree either to disagree or to
not talk about politics or whatever i
mean i think my family in argentina is
an example of that where in argentina
all my family is basically on the left
but you have people who love christina
kirschner and that whole regime and
people who don't like it and
typically they just agree not to talk
about politics at family gatherings and
it sort of works okay
gotcha okay so i guess the next step for
me is to figure out where and i guess
it's where i'm struggling personally
where my values lie like i'm
yeah family no matter what or
when your family's pretty
a bunch of jerks maybe maybe not yeah
and i mean listen there's a difference
between
there's people who think there should be
a 10 flat tax on everything i was like
okay all right well that's i mean we can
disagree on that versus
i think the jews are the devil and are
going to hell that's going to be someone
very difficult to put differences aside
with you know
right right and i think i think at first
it was leaning towards the
the first example right and then when
trump came out and um
kind of made it more normal to be
a little bit more racist to be a little
bit more vocal about these views yeah i
started to see a different side of my
family as they saw that that that was
okay to say these things right yeah yeah
yeah
and so now it's like
you know and then also as i'm growing
older
28
having been more developed cognitively
and being able to kind of like recognize
these things as you know when you're 12
14 15 not being able to recognize
these these types of things well let us
know how it works out
yeah yeah thanks because i appreciate
the advice all right there's evan from
boston and that is going to do it for us
today we will take more calls next week
i look forward to it
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
it is that time of the week time for the
mailbag every day we get hundreds of
emails and we feature
around 10 of them a week on the friday
show if you have something to say you
can email info
davidpakman.com we'll occasionally
feature
a twitter reply or a facebook post or
whatever really but info davidpakman.com
is the place to email
let's start with something ugly we'll
build to the good messages but we're
going to start with something ugly uh
this is someone named l.a mob squad who
wrote to me about the subject you and
your senile diaper-wearing potus
will forever be to blame for the
collapse of the u.s and are standing on
the world stage
this is very weaponized i'm warning you
la mob squad writes
i hope you realize these four years will
be looked back at historically as a
humiliating disastrous period in usa
history directly caused by delusional
loons like you
who make up the democratic party
remember i'm not a democrat i don't care
about the democratic party
you can say completely ridiculous and
illogical bs all you want but we both
know we're way past p-a-s-e-d the point
where you can deflect blame and pretend
that the usa the west's drastic decline
fall on the world stage of this
magnitude is falling on the shoulder of
anybody other than senile joe biden
wait
gas prices are up everywhere it's not
just joe biden
many countries are figuring out what to
do about russia and ukraine's not just
joe biden i don't even know what he's
talking about
um going on to say there's no way you or
anybody else can make a case to the
contrary while sounding even a tiny bit
reasonable nope we're way past that this
u.s collapse will forever be on your
shoulders and it's effing hilarious in a
super disappointing kind of way
you talk about trump and then bring a
guy in and you make us look like an
effing weak crumbling decrepit senile
old bastard suffering from the severest
case of brain rot good job david y'all
sure know how to pick them oh and don't
think it's over we're one year in wait
till china takes taiwan you all just
need to shut the f up forever
you have so much nerve to even still be
talking you should never say another
effing word to us again with this joke
of a first year that's historically bad
lol never again
sit the f down and be quiet you've effed
enough s up already i can't wait till
2024.
the red wave is going to be
breathtakingly glorious and we both know
it thanks for sucking but shut the f up
from now on please y'all have been
humiliated take the loss and sit down
thanks and then a bunch of clown emojis
very
very weaponized needs no response but
this is just a reminder one of the
things i like to talk about is
there are people with whom we can sit
and talk and figure out political
differences what is the role of the us
on the world stage diplomatically
militarily whatever what should the top
tax rate be how should education be
funded there's people we can disagree
with but talk to
these are the types of people where i
believe they are essentially a lost
cause in in all practical terms they are
a lost cause
next email is from sophie
sophie says hey david biden has chosen
his words very carefully regarding the
role of the us military in putin's war
on russia and so has gensake this has
been the wording the u.s will not put
military boots on the ground boots on
the ground is used over and over and
over there are many types of military
action the u.s is capable of outside of
literal soldiers on the ground
yeah uh this is a good point and it's
something we've we've talked about
before
i believe that it is not
an accidental choice of words or a
coincidental choice of words they are
saying boots on the ground because
probably everything else is on the table
quite frankly and you know people email
me about drones i don't know that'd be a
big step
but i think that it is not an accident
and they are there's a reason they are
talking about boots on the ground as the
line because they want to leave open the
possibility of
up to almost anything else
uh short of that and we we may soon see
it
chris writes in
about william barr's interviews
and here's chris's view barr in his
interview is simply giving trump cover
to protect him from criminal liability
by opening the door for an insanity plea
should the prosecution ever make enough
headway besides that how could he
describe such an obvious state of
delusion and then turn around and say
he'd vote for such a person i think the
answer to that is barr's just a horrible
person
that alone should send a red flag us to
his credibility he betrays himself
gangsters one and all as with what most
of trump's loyal supporters he's most
likely being extorted
yeah i don't i just don't know about
that i i just i'm just not sure about
that um we don't we don't have evidence
of that
and uh it's not clear to me
that uh that that's what's going on so i
i would be careful about making those
assessments it's conceivable bar is
trying to give trump cover
but you know he's being blackmailed
let's just be sure we know what we're
saying and that there's evidence behind
it i'm just not sure about that
mark wrote in with a correction sir you
are mispronouncing nukes
dear sir i'm a big fan of your show but
i recently noticed you have a penchant
for mispronouncing nukes as nukes
case in point your recent video titled
concerns grow that putin will use
nuclear weapons pronounced properly it
should rhyme with dukes not rebukes
dukes
not rebukes
do
you okay i know you're a stickler for
pronunciation want to make you aware
keep doing doing what you're doing
except for nukes yeah
nuclear nuclear nuclear nukes nukes
i hear the difference nuke sounds more
natural to me
and i'm gonna take that liberty
given that english is my second language
i think i'm sticking with nukes i've
i've been this people have written to me
before and they've said david you use a
liquid u when you pronounce the word new
some people say a new car new
i say a new car
i think i'm going to stick with it i
like it
matthew writing in about our sponsor
nebia shower
this is pretty clever hey david i had a
question about your sponsor nebia are
these the types of shower heads where
the water comes out dripping very
quietly do you have to take a shower 10
to 15 times as opposed to once
i like to look into the elements of
bathrooms very strongly before making a
purchase please let me know thank you
yes a very very important question the
nebia shower heads are not the water is
not quietly dripping out it is it is
lower water use but it powerfully comes
out you could bathe an elephant with it
if you needed to if you could if you
could fit the elephant in your bathtub
you could bathe it but i i get the trump
references thank you
jake wrote in about the mma fighter
bryce mitchell
who
recently went on a delusional right-wing
rant with right-wing conspiracies about
ukraine jake wrote it's notable that
guys like that mma fighter have changed
their thinking so much since the u.s
invasion of iraq back then it was if we
would don't fight them over here we'll
have to fight them if we don't sorry
back then it was if we don't fight them
over there we'll have to fight them over
here
now under a democratic president they
have no concern about what's happening
in other parts of the world even though
it's obviously atrocious and it could
bring war over here
that's johnny who i guess also goes by
jake yeah this it shouldn't surprise us
that there is a stunning level of
hypocrisy from a lot of these people
now i agree with not sending not putting
boots on the ground in ukraine joe biden
has said that from the beginning he
should stick to it i think it's the
right thing and i think he will stick to
that by the letter of what he said
but it shouldn't be ignored
that when the right wants to justify
military incursions as they did in iraq
in 2003 and have done elsewhere
and continued involvement in afghanistan
for as long as that went on nearly 20
years
they often say it's not that we want to
be there but if we don't fight them
there we'll be fighting them here
and many right-wingers accept that and
they say that's good that's common sense
that's logic
you're absolutely right
in this particular case they're not
saying it they're just saying no we
shouldn't do it while by the way at the
same time
saying biden is being weak
they would criticize biden if he quote
started a war as they love to say
and at the same time they say biden is
weak for not doing enough the point is
these are bad faith actors you can't
please them
and so we should pay enough attention to
know what they're saying but i don't
think we need to take them very
seriously they're not good faith actors
next email today is about youtube's
about rt's youtube channel rt being
russian state media propaganda uh hi
david today this i love this the the
the delightful naivete of this email hey
david today i found a russian-backed
youtube channel called rt
all of the videos are pro-russia and
anti-west if you read the comments on
the videos they are all pro-russia as
well many of the misleading videos on
this channel are disgusting i just
wanted to get your opinion on what if
you think youtube should shut it down
and join the other hundreds of companies
that have already pulled out of russia
yeah so first of all
i
i envy
someone who has not
been suffering through
knowing that rt exists and the content
that they produce for the last decade
now as many of you know i used to appear
as a guest on rt when invited thinking
i'll go wherever and give my views
but once it became clear to me that like
barely anyone was watching this stuff in
the us
and it's not even worth my time to
appear nor do i want to be associated
with it in any way i just started
turning down all of my all uh invites
and i've probably turned down i don't
know eight invitations there over the
last few years
um i would love instead to just not even
be aware that there was this propaganda
thing being disseminated in the u.s now
that being said for the person emailing
youtube demonetized the rt channel and
marked it as russian state media and rt
america ceased operations so it's over
for now at least and uh that's a good
thing that's a good thing
last email today is from julia about the
term strong men
julius says hey david
please stop referring to machiavellian
mad men as strong men it's a misleading
connotation when what they actually are
is cowardly psychopathic bullies who con
and rely on their minions to brutalize
and oppress others for their own
narcissistic gain
that term gives people away to positive
idea about them and allows the weak
minded a rationale to follow them yeah
that's probably true i mean sometimes
i'll refer to
a
authoritarians i think the problem is
sometimes they're not literally
dictators so to just call them dictators
isn't accurate which is why i'll often
say authoritarian strong men
but it would be good to have a different
term maybe dictatorial authoritarians or
wannabe dictators instead of strong men
i'm open to that i'm open to that but uh
a good point julia i appreciate you
emailing in about that if you have a
topic for discussion for the mailbag
you can email info
davidpakman.com please don't abuse the
email address in all seriousness we get
a lot of crap in there
uh but you can email info at
davidpakman.com we have a great bonus
show coming up for you today you get
access to the bonus show by becoming a
member at joinpacman.com
[Music]
you